karine bechet goal of kobo jours
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin pour parler donc de cette
réunion aujourd'hui en visioconférence
entre deux je baille donne et vladimir
poutine en plein pic de tension autour
de l'ukraine alors c'est quoi l'enjeu
premier de cette rencontre cessé de
faire baisser la pression
officiellement oui ensuite il est
important de voir que les ans quels sont
les enjeux pour les états unis d'un côté
et pour la russie de l'autre côté pour
les états unis il est évident que
lorsque l'on voit sur fond de
négociations avec poutine le paquet de
sanctions qui est en discussion qui va
jusqu'à déconnecter la russie de swift
lorsque l'on voit les différentes
déclarations extrêmement agressive
des responsables politiques américains
accusant la russie d'une escalade du
conflit or rappelons quand même que ce
n'est pas elle qui a une armée actifs
sur le territoire de l'ukraine qui
tirent contre sa propre population sont
armés et sur son propre territoire et
lorsque vous avez un conflit qui est
actif à vos frontières
évidemment vous surveiller pour voir ce
qu'il se passe donc du côté américain
nous sommes si vous voulez dans une
espèce de plan de communication qui doit
cacher en quelque sorte les réel acte
politique du côté russe a
peut-être encore une fois essayé de
faire passer le message
encore une fois faire comprendre que la
russie a une armée sur son territoire
russie n'a pas l'intention d'agresser
d'ukraine comme le discours médiatique
et politique impose la formulation même
si la question qui se pose en fait
réellement n'est pas celle de la
question de l'agression ou de
l'occupation de l'ukraine à part la
russie puisque actuellement l'ukraine
est juridiquement et defacto occupée par
les forces militaires de l'otan mais
c'est la question de la protection des
populations civiles hudon base qui
manifestement ne seront pas protégés ni
par l'europe ni par les états unis ni
par le temps ce que nous voyons
qui ne peut être protégé que par la
russie du coup dans ce contexte ce qu'on
se peut s'attendre à des actes concrets
à des décisions concrètes après cette
réunion où il s'agira les avantages d'un
dialogue où chacun expliquera sa
position
comme le porte parole du kremlin l'a
justement souligné a priori la russie en
tout cas nathan strictement aucun acte
concret n'oublions pas que les
présidents russe et américain se sont
déjà rencontrés il ya quelques mois de
ça
depuis il n'y a eu strictement aucune
amélioration concrète de la situation
sur aucun plan des relations
internationales
donc
aucun acte concret ne pourra être
adoptée il serait déjà bien que ceux qui
ont été adoptés soit appliquée et que en
plus et ils soient interprétés de la
même manière et des potées russe et du
côté américain puisque lorsque les
etats-unis par là de renforcer les
accords de minsk pour eux les accords de
miss doivent être exécutés non pas par
le cren à mai par la russie qui pourtant
est garante et non partie de ces accords
donc là aussi il ya un problème
ré expliquer les positions oui
certainement mais réellement peut-on
imaginer que le président américain
n'ait pas au courant du contenu et des
accords de minsk peut-on réellement
imaginer que le président américain soit
surpris qu'un état souverain des places
des forces armées de manière monde
hostile sur son propre territoire
lorsqu'il ya un conflit ouvert à sa
frontière sérieusement non je ne pense
pas donc il ya un moment donné il faut
faire attention à ne pas s'enfermer
simplement dans la communication parce
que la communication ne remplacera
jamais la politique si l'on veut
réellement gouverner vous le disiez lors
de leur premier sommet à genève c'était
en juin 2021 vladimir poutine et joe
biden avait pourtant affiché une volonté
d'apaisement on le voit bien c'est pas
le quincaillier qu'est ce qui explique
cette position de washington aujourd'hui
il faut toujours différencié comme je
vais redire et la communication d'un
côté et la réalité la politique de
l'autre
aux formellement les etats-unis et leurs
présidents successifs ne veulent pas
d'un conflit ouvert direct avec la
russie ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ne soit
pas dans une logique réelle politique de
confier avec la russie ce qui explique
cette différence entre d'un côté et les
grands sourires et ce qui ressort aussi
de la culture occidentale savoir mener
des négociations très dures tout en
gardant le sourire mais le sourire ne
veut strictement rien dire et d'un autre
côté des actes politiques les décisions
qui réellement sont prises lors ce
qu'ils appellent par exemple que les
états unis appellent par exemple les
pays européens à renforcer les
livraisons d'armes à l'ukraine on ne
peut pas dire que ce soit fait pour
pacifier la situation entre les états
unis entre parlant entre l'ukraine et le
dombass donc ici ce qui est important
c'est ne pas se fier aux discours qui
sont prononcés s'attacher aux faits
réels aux décisions qui sont prises qui
sont mises en oeuvre à ce qui se passe
sur le terrain et surtout la russie
devrait peut-être sortir enfin de cette
rhétorique éternelle du si jamais l'on
porte atteinte à la population dont
basse on va réagir puisque formellement
et defacto la population du domptage
depuis des années vit dans une situation
extrêmement difficile sur le plan humain
après la question est celle de savoir
qui va réellement la protéger et la
protéger ce n'est pas suffisant de faire
rentrer ses dirigeants dans le parti
russie unie ni de fournir de l'aide
humanitaire il faut une position
stratégique d'ensemble qui fasse qui ne
demande pas que c'est en quelque sorte
zone d'intérêt soit respecté mais qui
impose ses propres zones d'intérêt une
chope dans un rapport de force si la
russie ne rentre pas dans ce rapport de
chance à valverde
qu'est-ce qui peut aussi compter
aujourd'hui sur le soutien de pays
européens qui a été affichée avant cette
réunion c'est une autre pression envers
moscou
tout à fait puisque comme nous le voyons
sur tous les plans quasiment les pays
européens malheureusement sont devenus
des satellites atlantiste ils ne
défendent pas l'intérêt du continent
européen sinon il aurait déjà dû lutter
contre le maidana l'époque ils devraient
se révolter contre les persécutions par
le régime de kiev aujourd'hui contre les
populations habitant en ukraine or nous
voyons que la politique européenne est
une peau rides politique atlantiste qui
va à l'encontre de l'intérêt des
populations européennes et qui
malheureusement entretien le conflit en
ukraine parce qu'il faut être honnête ce
conflit est important pour les états
unis dans leur logique de gouvernance
globale tant qu'il est actif ils n'ont
strictement aucun intérêt à voir ce
conflit résolu et les européens
les européens eux en tout cas les
populations européennes ont intérêt à ce
que ce conflit soit résolu puisque c'est
un compliquer leur coûte cher et c'est
un coût qui est potentiellement
extrêmement dangereux au niveau du haut
de la déstabilisation de la stabilité
son continent européen qu'il induit sans
compter également toutes ses forces
extrêmes d'extrême droite qui se et qui
se manifeste et qui sont retenus et qui
sont armés en ukraine et qui peuvent
très facilement déstabiliser également à
côté et comme nous avons vu par exemple
en biélorussie lorsque certains puisque
y ont été envoyés donc l'europe elle n'a
pas intérêt à ça la question est de
savoir quels sont les intérêts défendus
par les gouvernants européens alors le
projet d'adhésion de kiev à l'alliance
atlantique lui n'a toujours pas vu le
jour malgré les demandes insistantes de
deux tiers mehdi de l'otan reste
sceptique encore
les pays de l'otan c'est pareil on
besoin de cette situation qui est en
quelque sorte glissante et à dire que
d'un côté l'on vous promet l'intégration
est comme ça où l'on met en place déjà
des bases des programmes est en quelque
sorte on a pris le contrôle du pays sur
cette promesse mais dans la mesure où il
ya un conflit ouvert et comme la
distante envers l'ukraine a tout le
soutien des pays de l'otan mais elle ne
peut pas compter sur l'assistance
militaire qui est dû
et membre de l'otan et c'est justement
cette clause qui bloque l'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'otan pour les pays de
l'otan c'est que s'ils veulent entraîner
ukraine dans un puits et quitte à ce
qu'elles s'y consume qui ce qu'est ce
que s'ils perdent ça ça n'est pas leur
problème mais eux ne veulent pas avoir à
assumer derrière
merci beaucoup karine bechet golovkov
pour votre éclairage ce matin dans la
matinale je me rappelle vous êtes
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou